let's let's focus on the browns andrew
barry gm of the team
here he is talking about otto beckham
jr's rehab from his torn acl
in uh the 2020 season
i'll say this about perhaps all of our
guys they're all progressing really well
um and that includes odell i mean i
think he's he's right on track
anything changed with him in terms of uh
the role you see on
him on this team going forward and uh
potentially fitting in with the the rest
of the offense the way it played so well
down the stretch
last year without him no i think he's a
dynamic player who can be incredibly
productive in this system so we're
looking forward to getting him back
scale of one to ten miles what are the
chances otto beckham
jr is with the browns in 2021
ah interesting i think i think an eight
i i think that
they should keep him because if odell
beckham jr is healthy
then he's exactly the piece that that
offense i think needs in order to take
itself
to the next level and i know that the
offense got better
once odell beckham jr got hurt yes that
it was unequivocally true but
i think the other aspect of that is and
kevin stefanski talked about this a few
times
they were still getting to know the
players because there was no off season
there was a limited training camp so
by the time odell beckham jr goes out
it's like all right we really
are starting to figure out what we
should call what we
shouldn't call what baker mayfield is
great at
and as the season goes on then i think
you see that and i also
think when you look at like that chiefs
playoff game that they played and that
they ended up losing
that's the kind of role that odell
beckham jr can play
that the browns really really need they
need somebody to take the top off of
defense they need somebody
who can be a dynamic receiver now
kendall dell beckham be that kind of
dynamic receiver coming off an acl
tear we'll have to see but i think that
at least for right now
it makes way more sense for the browns
to keep him than it would for the browns
to get rid of him
his salary is guaranteed as a practical
matter injury guaranteed until march 17
or 19
something like that when it becomes
fully guaranteed they can't cut him
because of the torn acl he can't pass a
physical
so i've got several different points
that i'm going to refer to as of the
start of the league year it's a 10
he'll be on the roster start a training
camp it's a nine
start of the regular season eight and a
half
trade deadline six and a half because i
think there's a chance
once he shows he's healthy and once the
browns realize
we really don't need him to do our
offense the way we want to do our
offense and if anything his presence
is a drag on baker mayfield going
through his progressions because he
feels like he has to hold onto the ball
a little bit longer until obj comes open
and
there's this constant got to get in the
ball got to get him the ball i could see
him being traded to someone once he
establishes he's healthy
between the start of the season and the
tuesday after week eight
see that makes a lot of sense to me but
i didn't know we would be able to play
the game in four different spots
so you're always waiting for me in the
mood
yes there are no official rules of scale
of one to ten
it's whatever you want them to be here's
brad holmes lions general manager
on how he feels about the quarterbacks
in this draft even though he is just
about
12 days away from officially acquiring
jared goff from the rams
i i think that the quarterback class is
good this year
uh i i think i i i like the crop of
quarterbacks
that are coming out in in this year's
draft so
that's obviously uh always a very very
important
important position you know i think the
quarterback position
in general um what's cool about this
year is that
you know they're all they're in all
different flavors you know you have
a guy that actually can do it all can
you know
do it from the pocket do it with his
legs you have another guy that's
probably a little bit more does it with
his legs a little bit more being
creative
um there's another guy that actually
probably does it more from the pocket so
all the all the different flavors makes
it very very intriguing in terms of when
you're looking across the whole scope
of you know the the class of these
quarterbacks
as i mentioned earlier sims sees six
guys who could go in round one
the lion's sitting there at number seven
two guys at a minimum will be gone
before the lions are on the clock the
question is whether or not a mac jones
or one of the other quarterbacks is
taken
before number seven and then the
question becomes what do the lions do
if a quarterback that they potentially
like is there
at seven so what are the chances they go
quarterback at seven miles scale of one
to ten
i think it's i think it's a seven or
seven and a half to eight
because if i am brad holmes and if i'm
dan campbell i want to find my guy who
is going to be
the guy the alpha of the future and so i
i think that
when you are in that position and in
theory
you might not be there ever again you
know you at least want to not be
drafting that high ever again they
probably will just based on the way it
seems like they know that this is going
to be a multi-year process with detroit
they probably may have an opportunity to
select in the top 10 again but
if they're one of those guys that you
really fall in love with
and one of them at least is one of those
quarterbacks is at least going to be
there at number seven overall when they
pick
then i think you have to be able to
choose him because
i think about the cardinals and what
they did trading up to get josh rosen
and then obviously they were bad the
next year and so they picked a number
one overall and they picked kyle murray
can we really say
that the cardinals made that much of a
mistake by drafting
josh rosen i don't know i mean they had
another opportunity and they've
certainly made it right since then so
if you have this opportunity and there's
a guy you think you love
then i would say go for it but i also
think it's kind of funny that brad
holmes is talking about drafting
quarterbacks and how much he likes them
and
almost making it seem like ice cream and
neapolitan and flavors and things like
that when he also was part of the team
that drafted jared goff in 2016 so it's
not like they have a
don't have a quarterback that he knows
well mike that's right
and you know part of the game is to make
it look like you
are going to take a quarterback because
that gives value to that pick in the
event that someone wants to trade up and
get it
and it's also imperative that they do
their homework on all the quarterbacks
so they know what that pick is worth
if someone is trading up to get the
quarterback because they're not trading
up because they just want to be able to
say
hey we had the seventh pick in the draft
they're trading up because
there's a guy they want and if it's a
quarterback then you need to know
everything there is to know about that
quarterback so you can have
meaningful trade negotiations about what
that guy is truly worth because that's
who you're trading
you're trading that quarterback not the
seventh pick in the draft so either way
they need to do the work they need to
understand and along the way if they
fall in love with one of the guys
and says we can say we could groom him
for a year behind jared goff
then uh so be it but i feel like goff's
a two-year
option anyway because of his contract
but uh yeah again you have to go into
this
with open eyes open heart open mind and
you may find a guy who's your
quarterback for as long as matthew
stafford was
all right one more real quickly brian
gudykoon the packers general manager
here he is this week talking about 2020
first-rounder jordan love potentially
getting
some reps this season i think it's very
important for jordan
to get as many live reps and that's not
just him but all young players
specifically quarterbacks
i think as we move if that does
transpire we get to the three preseason
games
um i don't i think it prior to last year
i probably would have told you that
wasn't
going to concern me as much but after
going through a season without preseason
games
i i realize how valuable and how
important that they are
with jordan specifically yeah i think it
was disappointing we weren't able to get
them out there
in the preseason this year uh looking
forward to it this year the more the
more the better
um guys get better through plan um
you know practice is always important
but the live game reps for for all
players is
something you can't replace
scale of one to ten what are the chances
that jordan love gets meaningful reps
in 2021 oh by the way aaron rodgers
still on the team and will be on the
team
see well it depends on what date you're
asking me about this because if it's the
month of august
and the definition of meaningful because
meaningful for him should be even
playing at all because he didn't and he
was the third string
quarterback and he was inactive for game
day basically all year so i'm gonna say
in august it's a 10
and then once we get to september it's a
two because he needs to play
in the preseason if there are preseason
games and i think we can all anticipate
that there are going to be three with
the 17 game season that's at least the
way the wind is blowing so
jordan love certainly needs to play
sometime
in order to be somewhat prepared to be
the backup quarterback to aaron rodgers
and then once that happens i mean unless
aaron rodgers gets hurt i don't think
that there's any chance that guy is
seeing the field
yeah look i i think that the chances of
jordan love getting meaningful reps
in the regular season is one or less
than one
and the only way it's higher than that
is if aaron rodgers gets injured and i
do not want to be accused by anyone of
directly or indirectly putting the jinx
on aaron rodgers
by talking openly about the possibility
that he will be injured in fact i've
already said too much
about it miles well i think you probably
have yes we should probably just stop
talking huh
so jordan love uh very very low chance
that he's going to play this year
however good coons made some comments
that would suggest that it
oh no it wasn't goody it was nathaniel
hackett the offensive coordinator you
wrote the post at pft
the idea of they want jordan love to
make the offense his own
it's just it's just it's
it's awkward because he's under contract
three more years
fifth year option at some point in the
next four years
we're getting these vibes he's going to
be the quarterback and
aaron rodgers may want to stay for at
least four more years so
the rubber is going to meet the road at
some point and whether that means aaron
rodgers
hits the road it's it's not something to
ignore
and it does create tension but that
tension
i think helped the packers miles get to
13-3 last year
yeah probably did but i i did kind of
find that weird when he says we want him
to make the offense his own it's like
how can you possibly
make the offense your own win sensibly
you're going to be a backup quarterback
and unless and thank you hackett knows
something that we don't and aaron
rodgers is not going to be there
in 2021 i mean that is still aaron
rodgers offense
and it should be aaron rodgers offense
until he proves that he's no longer
playing at a level
where it should be aaron rodgers offense
and so yeah that's that's an interesting
thing i mean obviously you
want the quarterback that you take in
the first round to feel like he has
some sort of ownership over something so
that if he does need to come in there he
feels comfortable
but i think there's a difference between
comfort and then
taking control where it's his if that
makes sense mike
and by the way there is potential with
jordan love there's been so much talk
this week about sims 2021 quarterback
rankings last year it went joe burrow
justin herbert jordan love to a ton of
iloa so
high enough opinion of love to put him
ahead of tonga vailo
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports